got a lot of new um eyeballs after our
Matt R
conversation um last week who knew dude
by the way it's so amazing to me and I'm
super happy for him by the way but you
know anything you you mention his name
in the title of something you you're
going to get a ton of views yeah whether
it's good or bad eyes but yeah it's like
putting his name in anything is like any
publicity is good publicity at this
point I I I I do want to say a couple of
things real quick um and it was quite an
ex uh um an interesting social
experiment for me posting that and it's
told me how it showed me um how far I've
come emotionally with what I I guess
what I would call emotional
intelligence uh because I think that's
basically the term for how in control
you are right I will say this if you
depending on if you watched the short
one minute clip or the 9 Minute clip
talking about you probably got different
things away there there's a lot of
context that is missed sure from the 9
Minute clip to the one minute clip the
one minute clip is your main points but
the 9 Minute clip really gives like an
allaround better
explanation of of of of what we were
talking about but reading the
comments was and I guys I I I want I
want to let you know I went through as
much as I can and and erased people
saying negative [__] or name calling I I
I don't have time to go through and
erase all of it when I saw something I
was like that's it's not necessary there
were a couple out of pocket comments yep
and I will say part of that is my fault
for how it was cut yes because I did
call people touchy [__] now I want to
make clear I was not calling people who
have the victims of Domes domc violence
touchy [__] in the longer clip that
is very evident yep yep and I when I was
saying you don't get to pick and choose
what you don't get to pick and choose is
what you get to pick and choose what you
think is funny you don't get to pick and
choose what other people find funny
that's right that's right and what was
really Co interesting to me is is
messages from people who have been fans
of mine for a long time I recognize
their names and it's quick it's so funny
how quickly people turn may it was like
yeah typical I should have known by the
dumb [__] you and your son talk about
stick to one question was stick to
talking about
sweatshirts it made me [__] laugh but
I will tell you what I meant by how far
I've come emotionally in the past I
would have let
that I would have gone in like yeah D
you know I would have said something
like okay but you're still following me
and on my page M so like you know what I
mean it's called fan behavior is what we
call that but here's what alarmed
me what alarmed me and and as I've grown
out of it what alarms me a little bit is
how easily manipulated people are and
when I say that that doesn't even mean
necessarily manipulated to do my bidding
but I
can make you feel a certain way just by
words MH I can make you feel a certain
way just by saying
I don't agree with you because when
you're mad at me when people are mad at
me when they were mad in those comment
sections at other
people basically they're mad because
they're saying I'm mad because you don't
think the way I think right and I think
it's
just a bummer I I I I I just do like we
have to be able to have some civil
discourse and I want to make it one more
time super super super clear
guys nobody thinks domestic violence
well nobody who isn't a scumbag thinks
domestic violence is funny however that
doesn't mean you can't make funny
domestic violence jokes is the joke
funny we you can all pretend to be
incredibly and clutch your pearls but
every one of you has have laughed and I
don't know if it makes you feel better
because your friend told you the joke or
you laughed behind closed doors but
every one of you have laughed at a joke
that you would not tell in public you
are allowed to decide for
yourself what is acceptable yeah you're
allowed to decide for
yourself but what was a clear indication
that there's no line is that there were
more domestic violence
survivors
saying I didn't mind the joke or we have
to to learn to laugh that's how we heal
or any number of things or there were
some who were like hey I don't mind the
the domestic violence jokes I just
didn't think that one was funny yeah by
the way nobody's saying you have to
think Matt's funny or any of us but it's
art yeah and you know what I mean
anyways but then also uh to round that
off whether you're you know whether you
found it funny or not and you went into
the comment and you were just like hey I
just I just never really found him funny
or didn't find that joke funny it
doesn't and I will say this not in
defense of those people but it them
leaving their opinion on that doesn't
open the floor for everybody to come out
and be like hey you're stupid you're
obviously like didn't take he didn't
take comedy lessons from you this and
that this and that like there was one
specific woman on your post who just
got Rampage and I'm going to take a
little responsibility for that and how
that clip was cut just because it it if
you weren't paying attention or how or
really didn't see the full nine minutes
but if you weren't paying attention
because on my clip I never called you a
[__] for not thinking it was funny
right I I and and I sh and I open the
door for insults with that minute clip
and I by the way I never want to be that
person right I I actually really want to
be a person who Bridges these two groups
together who Sparks a conversation but
also can spark like a civil convers
because that because I really feel like
that's what it is and it's so funny in
today's society there were people on the
page who like I said who have been fans
forever who are like unfollow and I'm
like by the way
guys not
nobody you're not going to agree 100%
with anybody no and if you do that's
called a cult and it's very un uh
unhealthy very unhealthy
I saw some people on my page who left
comments like that's right or [__]
yeah and I know for a fact there are
some jokes that would make them say too
far I know one of the people everybody's
got a line but but that which is my
point which is just draw the line for
yourself but just don't draw it for
other
people oh yeah hey man hey
man
oh yeah hey man hey